TERALLY IS OUR NATIONAL
TREASURE, THESE LIVES, THESE
PRECIOUS KIDS, ALL LIVES
DEFINITELY MATTER
SH.
THAT INCLUDES EIGHT YEARS OF THE
OBAMA-BIDEN PRESIDENCY AND VICE
PRESIDENCY.
BUT THEY COULDN'T BE BOTHERED AT
THE TIME.
THEY NEVER ADDRESSED -- THEY
BARELY MENTION THE EPIDEMIC OF
VIOLENCE IN OBAMA'S HOME CITY OF
CHICAGO.
THEY DIDN'T LIFT A FINGER.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN TRY.
THEY DIDN'T DO NEXT TO NOTHING.
THEY BARELY SPOKE ABOUT THE
CARNAGE IN ONE OF AMERICA'S
MAJOR CITIES, SO YOU'VE GOT TO
ASK YOURSELF THE QUESTION.
WHY IS THAT?
IN SHORT, IF DEMOCRATS, THE
MEDIA MOB, IF THEY CAN'T USE A
SHOOTING TO TRY AND VILIFY
REPUBLICANS OR CONSERVATIVES,
WATCH, THEY JUST IGNORE IT?
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
THEN YOU LISTEN TO JOE BIDEN
BEFORE HE EVEN KNEW THE ACTUAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE SHOT YESTERDAY.
RUSHING TO POLITICIZE THIS.
SO NOW SADLY, LIKE ALWAYS, THEY
USED THE HORROR B6, TEXAS, TO
SCORE, WHAT, CHEAP POLITICAL
POINTS?
BECAUSE IF THEY REALLY CARED
ABOUT ALL THOSE KIDS, WHY DIDN'T
THEY LIFT A FINGER FOR JOE EIGHT
YEARS TO A VICE PRESIDENT
GIMMICK WHY DIDN'T YOU DO
ANYTHING?
LAST NIGHT BEFORE WE EVEN KNEW
THE ACTUAL REAL DEATH TOLL,
PRESIDENT BIDEN RACED, RUSHED IN
FRONT OF THE CAMERA, POLITICIZED
THE SHOOTING, LASHING OUT AT THE
SO-CALLED GUN LOBBY AND
MEANWHILE, ONE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN TAKES TO TWITTER AND
CALLS TED CRUZ [BLEEP]ING BABY
KILLER.
AND THEN THERE'S THIS LUNATIC
PHAEDO O'ROURKE, RUNNING FOR
STATEWIDE OFFICE, IF NOT GOING
WELL FOR HIM, SO TODAY HE
INTERRUPTED AN OFFICIAL PRESS
CONFERENCE IN UVALDE WITH HIS
VERY OWN POLITICAL STUNT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS CIRCUS.
YOU'RE OUT OF LINE.
SIR, YOU ARE OUT OF
.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE].
>> [BLEEP] WHY DON'T YOU GET OUT
OF HERE.
>> Sean: THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE AN INFORMED BRIEFING FOR
PARENTS, THE COMMUNITY, THE
GENERAL PUBLIC.
THERE WERE FAMILY MEMBERS OF
VICTIMS IN THAT ROOM.
THERE WERE PARENTS THERE IN THE
ROOM CRYING, BUT THERE IS BOZO,
DIDN'T SEEM TO CARE.
HE WANTED TO SEE HIS NAME IN THE
HEADLINES, HE WANTED TO RAISE
MONEY FOR HIS STRUGGLING
CAMPAIGN.
HE WANTED THE FOCUS TO BE ON
HIM, SO AS CBS NEWS EVEN
REPORTED, HE ORCHESTRATED THIS
DISGUSTING STUNT FROM BEGINNING
TO END.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> COULD YOU MAKE OUT WHAT WAS
BEING SAID BY BETO O'ROURKE?
>> WELL, I DID SEE WHAT HAPPENED
JUST BEFORE THE PRESS CONFERENCE
STARTED.
I WAS IN THE THIRD I'LL -- THIRD
ROW ON THE AISLE, RATHER, AND TO
PEOPLE ACROSS THE AISLE FROM ME
AND A MOMENT BEFORE THE PRESS
CONFERENCE STARTED THEY GOT UP
FROM THEIR SEATS WHEN HE WALKED
IN.
SO THEY WERE SEE HOLDERS FOR HIM
AND THEN HE SAT DOWN, SO HIS
PRESENCE WASN'T REALLY NOTICED
IN THE 15 OR 20 MINUTES THAT
PEOPLE WERE GATHERING INSIDE
BECAUSE HE WAS NOT IN THE ROOM.
SO THIS SEEMS THING VERY CLEARLY
STAGED BY BETO O'ROURKE AND HIS
CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: IT WAS STAGED AND HE
WILL LOSE THIS ELECTION BADLY,
AND BY THE WAY, HE'S ALL OVER
THE MAP NOW WHEN IT COMES TO
GUNS, THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
GO BACK IN TIME.
REMEMBER DURING HIS PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, THAT RUN, REMEMBER HE
BRAGGED OFTEN ABOUT WANTING TO
CONFISCATE YOUR GUNS AND HELL
YEAH HE'S COMING FOR YOUR ARs
ENTER AK-47S.
NOW AS A GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE
IN AN ELECTION YEAR CONVERSION,
HE'S TRYING TO DEFEND THE
SECOND AMENDMENT.
IF NOT WHAT DID BEFORE.
>> AMERICANS WILL -- WHO OWN
AR-15S, AK-47S, WILL HAVE TO
SELL THEM TO THE GOVERNMENT.
I FULLY EXPECT OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS TO TURN IN THEIR
AR-15s AND THEIR AK-47s.
>> ARE YOU IN FACT IN FAVOR OF
GUN CONFISCATION?
>> YES.
>> HELL YES WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
YOUR AR-15, OR AK 47.
>> I'M NOT INTERESTED IN TAKING
ANYTHING FROM ANYONE.
WHAT I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DO
IS DEFEND THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
>> Sean: NOW THAT HE'S RUNNING
FOR GOVERNOR HE WANTS TO DEFEND
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
NO, WE ARE NOT TO CONFISCATE
GUNS.
JUST THE TIP OF THAT -- ISN'T
THIS WHAT WE FIND SO REPULSIVE
ABOUT POLITICIANS?
THEY HAVE NO REAL CONVICTIONS
AND HE WILL SAY AND DO ANYTHING
TO GET ELECTED?
HE'S NO HERO HERE.
HE'S SPINELESS, HE'S AN OUT OF
WORK POLITICIAN, HE WANTS TO
FEEL IMPORTANT AND HE'S
POLITICIZING A TRAGEDY.
THE REAL HEROES, IF YOU WILL, IN
UVALDE, WHERE THOSE THAT RISKED
THEIR LIVES AND LIMB TO SAVE AS
MANY KIDS AS THEY COULD, AND
THEY DID, INCLUDING THE ELITE
BORDER PATROL OFFICIAL, THE ONE
THAT RUSHED INTO THE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL, THE ONE THAT RETURNED
FIRE AND ULTIMATELY KILLED THIS
MURDERER.
AND BY THE WAY, TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS.
THIS IS HIS HAT.
TAKE A GOOD LOOK AT T